-Chiwetel, nice to see you, bud.
-Thank you.
Nice to see you, too.
Pleasure to be here.
-Thank you.
Thank you so much
for doing the show.
I know you made it
back to London,
but the quarantine started
for you here in New York,
is that right?
-That's right, that's right.
I was in New York
when it all --
when it all kicked off,
which was -- I mean,
it was pretty intense.
It was intense for everybody,
of course, you know.
But it was pretty full-on
in New York.
And I ended up getting on
what they called
a repatriation flight,
you know, which sounded,
like, very Orwellian.
I was like the only person
in JFK.
-Wow.
-It was incredibly surreal.
Just pulling up just to the
terminal
and being in the only car
in the whole thing,
it was really -- it really
hit home at that point.
-Your family is -- Your mom
and dad are both from Nigeria?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And your dad, I read somewhere,
your dad was a singer, like,
a pretty famous musician, right?
-Yeah, he was.
He was a pretty famous musician
in Nigeria.
He was a doctor, as well.
But he was pretty big in kind of
sort of African high-life music,
with a lot of sort of jazz
and sort of funk influence.
And I, you know -- I mean,
it was, I mean, amazing for me
growing up and starting to
learn, when we'd visit Nigeria,
just how well known
he was there.
People just on the street would
break into his music, you know?
-And how old were you
when you saw that?
-I was like 7,
I guess, you know,
7, 8 years old
when I was kind of aware
that people were singing
my father's songs,
and it was just sort of
in random places in Nigeria.
And, you know, people would
break into his music,
and I would just be like
sort of getting it
and piecing it together
and realizing just
that sense of community
and the influence
that he was having.
-And your mom
was a backup singer?
-Yeah, she was a backup singer
in his band.
So, you know, they were like --
And actually, his mom, as well,
my grandmother
on my father's side
was also one of the backup
singers in the band.
So it was like
a little family affair.
-Did you think of getting into
music or your sisters?
-I did. I mean, I never had
my father's voice, sadly,
but I loved --
you know, he was --
his influence on me was just
I think about
in sort of entertainment
and being able to kind of
communicate with people
and how music
and for me then acting
was also a way
of expressing self, you know,
and, you know, thinking about
self-expression,
and thinking about sort of
self-understanding
and communicating that
with a group of people.
And that was the kind of --
I think that was
the sort of line that I took
that was sort of like his,
in a way.
-Yeah. That's wild
you got the bug right there.
That's pretty wild.
Then look what you've done
with everything.
I mean, you've just been
crushing it,
every single movie you do.
I mean, you're getting nominated
for Oscars.
It's like --
It's a pretty awesome career.
I want to talk about
"The Old Guard" on Netflix.
Big hit. Congrats on that.
-Thank you.
-That's kind of a fun thing,
too, to have a movie on Netflix.
'cause everyone's home
right now, so --
-Well, that is
a great advantage, you know,
that there is, like, a proper
captive audience for the movie.
It's amazing.
-Yeah, yeah.
You were saying somewhere
that you think
this is a big either
step forward in movies and film,
or is that because of
the Netflix part?
-Yeah, I mean, I think
it's all of it, you know?
"The Old Guard" I think is
a great film in its own right.
And I think it's been
brilliantly directed
by Gina Prince-Bythewood.
But also, it encapsulates,
I think, this idea of how film
and how media in broad terms
can really be inclusive
and how that is part of the --
With this film,
it's sort of an integral part
of the narrative
is this kind of sense
of inclusivity.
And everybody is represented
in the film.
All sorts of different groups,
people of different
walks of life
are all represented
in their own way.
And that's both in the story and
also behind the camera, as well.
And I think that that is
a really important marker.
And just how popular the film
has been, as well,
is just an important marker
for the way these things can go.
I think that that is
what's really going to be
a saving grace of our industry
and an important part
of our industry forward
is really representing
everybody.
-Yeah. I agree.
Can you set up the movie?
-So, "The Old Guard" is about
a group of mercenaries
led by Charlize Theron
who also happen to be immortal.
I mean, stop right there.
-I know, exactly.
You guys -- I mean, seriously,
she's amazing, unbelievable.
You guys together --
The film is great,
but she is just brilliant.
Oh, my gosh.
-Yeah. They kind of run into
a group of nefarious characters
who are not immortal,
but they are very sort of
ethically and morally ambiguous.
I would categorize myself
as one of that gang.
And then sort of chaos ensues.
-Yeah. It's very good.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Chiwetel Ejiofor
in "The Old Guard." Take a look.
[ Indistinct conversations ]
-Last overflight confirmed
the personnel on-site.
♪♪
No food or water
being brought in.
♪♪
-That means
they're moving them soon.
-And when they do, most likely,
they'll be separated,
and odds are,
you'll never find them again.
Has to be done quickly,
by the best.
And your team's
the best I've ever seen.
You can name your price.
♪♪
-We'll invoice you
when it's done.
-My thanks to Chiwetel Ejiofor.
"The Old Guard"
is available now on Netflix.
Stay safe, buddy.
Give my love to London, okay?